revista de prensa en directo américa ya
está conmigo en el estudio rosa pérez
más de un rosa feliz viernes en muy buen
día vamos a empezar como ya lo estábamos
adelantando con el medio gándará es una
dice cáscara vacía de presión extrema y
pensamientos suicidas persiguen a las
mujeres afganas bajo el régimen talibán
que fuerte este artículo que lo hizo ron
sino bits buenos días a un exacto es un
artículo muy conmovedor y señala que
pues las décadas de guerra en afganistán
así como la pobreza extrema en la que
vive gran parte de la población ya
marcan de por sí la salud mental de las
personas que viven en afganistán pero
que sobre todo entre las mujeres estos
cuadros que son frecuentes de depresión
ansiedad
pensamientos suicidas se han agravado
desde la llegada al poder de los
talibanes no y esto lo señalan pues
tanto testigos como psicólogos y
psiquiátricos y psiquiatras y entre
otras voces recogidas
destaca la de mariam rezaeí que es una
chica de 22 años que como otras diez mil
se vio forzada a dejar sus estudios
universitarios en la universidad de irak
y también su trabajo en una estación de
radio local y entre otras cosas declara
he perdido todo por lo que he trabajado
me hace perder los nervios me siento
como una cáscara vacía de ser humano de
aquí el título no estoy en cautividad y
solo espero mi muerte y bueno
básicamente lo que lo que estábamos
comentando no como el personal médico de
especializado en los tratamientos de
salud mental señala que además en lo que
se solía recomendar para las mujeres que
pasaban pues por estas situaciones que
eran pues entre otras cosas pues
centrarse más o motivarlas en sus
carreras profesionales salir del
aislamiento viajar pues ahora son
actividades todavía más restringidas
bajo el gobierno talibán y una experta
en salud global mental señala que los
suicidios son una de las únicas
potestades que tienen las mujeres
afganas sobre su propia vida de hecho
sus declaraciones son fuertes
el sacrificio de la vida a través de la
propia inmolación es en última instancia
la sola forma de defensa que le queda
solo tiene potestad sobre las decisiones
acerca de su muerte también está experta
señala que afganistán es uno de los
pocos países del mundo donde la tasa de
suicidio es mayor entre las mujeres que
entre los hombres y esto se relaciona en
gran parte con que también es uno de los
países con mayor tasa de violencia de
género contra las mujeres claro rosa y
por supuesto toda la represión también
que tienen ellas del lado estatal no es
para menos ojalá pues estas son estos
suicidios no se sigan cometiendo entre
las mujeres nosotros nosotros cambiamos
ahora información rosa vamos a alemania
con el der spiegel la sucia verdad sobre
las tecnologías limpias
este este texto no es muy extenso pero
básicamente hace un resumen de distintos
casos que ejemplifican lo que este
artículo señala como la paradoja detrás
del mayor proyecto del mundo
industrializado
y energética global para que el norte
pueda tener una vida así más no
aparentemente sostenible pues está
destruyendo grandes áreas de territorio
del sur global porque porque tanto las
turbinas eólicas como las placas solares
como nuestros dispositivos electrónicos
requieren de muchos recursos en
minerales que se extraen de gran parte
del sur global no de países como el
congo sudáfrica indonesia y precisamente
son en muchos casos empresas del norte
las que explotan estos recursos y en
esta explotación pues se contaminan ríos
se desplazan a poblaciones se gasta
muchísima agua en territorios que ya
sufren de sequías no y para resumir lo
que lo que señala este artículo es que
la demanda de todos estos dispositivos
electrónicos se calcula que irá en
aumento y lo único que podemos hacer
para frenar pues esta explotación y esta
enorme desigualdad es decrecer en
resumen material demográficamente
también apunta pero todo replantear
muchísimo nuestro modelo de consumo así
es rosa y vamos a hablar ahora de un
artículo que dice nos están marcando por
favor pongamos en contexto un poco
porque vamos a ver estos ritmos hemos
hemos seleccionado este artículo entre
decenas de proyectos periodísticos
seleccionados en el premio gabo no y
hemos precisamente he elegido este sobre
las protestas en chile que muestra
testigos historias de personas que
sufrieron a traumatismos oculares a raíz
del estallido social de 2019 en este
país andino que desencadenó recordemos
en la reforma constitucional que se está
desarrollando en estos momentos y de
hecho con 460 personas que sufrieron
traumas oculares chile se convirtió en
bueno una triste os tentadora de este
récord mundial y aquí vemos pues
distintos testigos también explicación
ella de las armas no que causaron este
tipo de lesiones pero porque nos hemos
querido fijar en el precio en el premio
cabo raúl sí porque hay un reportaje de
france 24 rosa segundo para ir con la
invitada al día si este reportaje pues
estamos súper contentos y felicitamos
desde aquí a nuestros compañeros y louis
de aurore que hicieron este reportaje
nosotros del sur vida y luchas de
indígenas y campesinos en colombia con
la ayuda de margot también nuestra
compañera aquí podemos ver unos segundos
y este vídeo que hay este reportaje que
recordemos está seleccionado al premio
gabo lo pueden encontrar en france24
nuestra página web así es rosa gracias
por toda la información feliz fin de
semana ya la dejo para que se vaya
descansar los vemos el lunes con más
revista de prensa nosotros vamos con
nuestra primera invitada del día
[Música]